POINTS PER GAME.
-- 59% MEANWHILE CURRY IS STUCK
IN THE -- AN AVERAGE OF 28
POINTS PER GAME ON 44%
SHOOTING.
AND GET THIS, 39% FROM THE
THREE POINT RANGE.
BUT, LOOK.
PEOPLE ARE MAKING THE ARGUMENT,
KATIE DOES HAVE A SORE SHOOTING
SOLDIER, SHOULDER.
DIFFICULT TO SAY WITH THREE
GUESSES THERE.
-- IS NOT IMPACTING HIS
NUMBERS.
THE NETS ARE NUMBER 2 IN THE
LEAGUE 3 POINT DEFENSES.
I THINK IT WILL BE ABLE TO SHUT
DOWN STEPH CURRY.
-- MAKING THE ARGUMENT THAT --
IS PLAYING.
BUT NONETHELESS, I AM ROCKING
WITH KD AND YOU GOT HIS HOME-
COURT.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO GET IT
DONE.
OBVIOUSLY, STEP THREE IS AN
UNBELIEVABLE SHOOTER BUT I JUST
THINK OF THIS GAME -- MAKE A
STATEMENT SO I AM ROCKING WITH
KD.
>> ERIN LOVES THAT PIC.
I HAVE WATCHED KEVIN TO RENT
CLOSELY BEING A GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS FAN.
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
I KNOW HE HAS BEEN OFF THE TEAM
A COUPLE OF YEARS BUT BEFORE
THAT WE HAD HIM FOR 3 YEARS.
AND, KEVIN DURANT SHOWS UP FOR
THOSE BIG-TIME GAMES.
HE SHOWS UP.
HE USUALLY SHOWS UP.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, THIS IS A
BIG GAME.
HE IS FACING HIS FORMER TEAM.
KEVIN DURANT WILL SHOW UP.
I THINK HE IS GOING TO SCORE
MORE POINTS THAN STEPH CURRY
TONIGHT.
THERE IS NOBODY ON THIS
WARRIORS TEAM.
THERE IS NOBODY IN THIS NBA
TEAM THAT CAN STOP KEVIN TO
RENT 101.
I THINK HE IS GOING TO GET HIS
TONIGHT.
THAT MEANS ARE THEY GOING TO
WIN?
NO, THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
MEAN THEY ARE GOING TO WIN.
BUT KD IS GOING TO GET HIS
TONIGHT.
SO, I AM GOING TO ROCK WITH KD.
BUT REMEMBER, AFTER THE GAME,
WE ARE GOING TO HIT UP ONE
PERSON AND HOOK YOU UP WITH THE
JERSEY.
FANDUEL IS ALSO OFFERING A
STIFF AND KD BOOST.
>> YES, THEY ARE.
>> THEY BOTH SCORE 30 OR MORE
POINTS, IT IS BEING BOOSTED
FROM +192+250.
SO, IF YOU THINK THEY ARE BOTH
GOING OFF, GET ON THE FANDUEL
APP AND SPRINKLE ON THAT --
ERIN, DO YOU LIKE THIS BOOST OR
NOT?
>> KATIE HAS RACKED UP 7. 30
POINT GAME SO FAR THIS SEASON.
MEANWHILE, STEPH CURRY HAS FOUR
30 OR MORE POINTS OF THE
SEASON.
SO, VERY GOOD-LOOKING CHANCE
THIS WILL HAPPEN.
IT'S GREAT MONEY AT +250.
SO, I WOULD BET THIS FOR SURE.
>> ERIN, LET ME HOP IN HERE.
LET ME HOP IN GETTING TO THIS
-- SHUT OUT TO EVERYONE WITH
THE SUNSET.
YOUNG GRAVY SAYS STUFF, HE WILL
NOT GO OFF TONIGHT AND KEVIN
WILL SCORE 35 SHUT UP.
YOU YOUNG GRAVY, WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
NICOLE MARCUS IS KATIE WILL
SCORE MORE POINTS TONIGHT,
PLAYING AGAINST HIS OLD SQUAD
AT HOME AND EVEN LEADING THE
LEAGUE IN SCORING.
BETTER BELIEVE HE WILL GIVE IT
TO THE WARRIORS.
-- NICOLE MARCUS, YOU ARE ALSO
WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
ERIN,  LET'S TALK MAJOR MARKETS
MONEYLINE AGAINST THE SPREAD
AND POINTS TOTAL FOR TONIGHT'S
GAME.
LET'S LOOK AT THE ODDS.
ERIN, WHAT DO YOU SEE HERE ?
AND WHAT DO YOU LIKE?
>> I'M GOING TO STICK WITH THIS
FIRST GAME SINCE EVERYONE IS
TALKING ABOUT THE WARRIORS IN
THE NETS.
GOLDEN STATE COULD COVER, THIS
IS A SECOND TIME THE WARRIORS
ARE UNDERDOGS.
3.5 EARLIER, OBVIOUSLY I LIKE
THAT BETTER THAN -- I WOULD
STILL TAKE A +3.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A
COMPETITIVE GAME, OF COURSE.
A LOT OF TALK SURROUNDING THE
WARRIORS AND YES, THEY ARE OFF
TO A GREAT START.
THEY WERE PLAYING AT HOME.
OF IT -- THEY WERE LAYING TEAMS
AS OPPOSED TO -- ABLE TO GET
THOSE WINDS AND START OFF A
LITTLE BIT SHAKY AND THEY WORK
WINNING FROM THE GAMES AT HOME.
BUT I THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE
A GAME WHERE THE WARRIORS CAN
KEEP IT CLOSE JUST LIKE THE
OTHER TWO LOSSES.
THEY ONLY LOST BY A COMBINED 7
POINTS IN THEIR TWO LOSSES.
SO, I'M GOING TO ROCK THE
GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS TO COVER
TONIGHT.
>> ERIN.
THAT'S A GREAT BET BECAUSE I AM
FOLLOWING YOU.
I'M GOING TO KEEP IT SIMPLE.
I'M JUST CONFUSED AS TO WHY THE
BETTER TEAM IS THE UNDERDOG
HERE.
WHY IS THE BETTER TEAM THE
UNDERDOG CARE?
DOES VEGAS HAVE SOMETHING UP
THE SLEEP?
I DON'T KNOW.
BUT I AM WALKING INTO THIS ONE
WITH MY TEAM.
I AM ROCKING WITH MY TEAM.
I AM NOT GOING -- OF THREE AND
I AM SPRINKLING ON THE
MONEYLINE.
-- WHEN IT IS FROM.
LET'S GO WITH WORRIERS -- IT IS
NOT ABOUT WHAT I THINK.
IT IS NOT ABOUT WHAT ERIN
THINKS.
IT'S ABOUT WHAT YOU GUYS THINK
. JUMP IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT
NOW.
GIVE ME -- T DUB 75 SAYS HARDEN
MIGHT SHOW OFF TONIGHT.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU SEE DUB.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
RITCHIE 21 SAYS, -- SCORE FOR
27.
SHOUT OUT TO YOUR.
>> WHAT WAS THAT, ERIN?
>> I LOVE WHEN PEOPLE ARE SO
SPECIFIC IN THE COMMENTS LIKE
HOW DID YOU COME UP WITH THAT
EXACT NUMBER?
>> HEY, THEY GET CREATIVE IN
THE COMMENTS.
THEY GET CREATIVE WITH THE
COMMENTS.
G QUINN 24 IS SAYING THAT WE
ARE AGREEING.
WE ALWAYS AGREE.
ME AND ERIN, WE ROCK.
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYBODY.
YOU ARE ALL  -- WE ARE ON THE
SAME PAGE.
BUT YOU ARE ALL WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
WE TALK WITH MAJOR -- WITH
ERIN.
WERE GOING TO PLAY A LITTLE
GAME CALLED LUCK OR NOT?
I AM GOING TO PUT UP -- YOU
GUYS GET IN THE COMMENTS AND
TELL ME IF IT IS A LOCK OR IT
IS NOT?
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
FIRST UP IS DONOVAN MITCHELL TO
BE THE TOP SCORER IN TONIGHT'S
SIXERS-CHAD'S GAME.
THE ODDS ARE AT -175.
IS THAT A LOCK OR NOT?
ERIN, WHAT IS YOUR TAKE?
>> SO, HE IS AVERAGING 26
POINTS PER GAME RIGHT NOW.
FOR ME, WHILE THIS MAY SEEM A
LOCK BECAUSE THERE IS GREAT
VALUE, THIS IS SOMETHING I
WOULD STAY AWAY FROM JUST
CONSIDERING THAT THEY HAVE NOT
REALLY BEEN PLAYING WELL AND ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE BALL, YOU
HAVE -- REALLY HAVING TO STEP
UP AND -- THE LAST FOUR GAMES
DUE TO COVERED BUT -- THE LAST
FOUR GAMES FOR 26 BY -- 23
POINTS.
THOSE ARE THE TWO AVERAGES.
AND I KIND OF INKING THIS GAME,
JUST CONSIDERING THAT ONE
PERSON IS GOING TO HAVE TO
STAND ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
BALL.
MAYBE THEY WOULD SCORE MORE
THAN DONOVAN MITCHELL, BUT HE
NEEDS TO GET TO BE ABLE TO DO
THIS.
I JUST WOULDN'T SET IT UP -175.
THAT'S TOO MUCH --.
>> ERIN, I AGREE.
I AGREE THAT -175  IS A LOT OF
JUICE.
BUT, HEY.
I THINK THAT DONOVAN MITCHELL
WILL BE THE TOP SCORER IN
TONIGHT'S GAME.
THINK HE IS THE BEST PLAYER ON
THE COURT AND USUALLY, WHEN
DONOVAN -- THE UTAH JAZZ -- IS
HAVING A GOOD GAME.
I'M GOING TO HOP IN THE
COMMENTS AND SEE WHO THEY LIKE.
COMMENTS.
-- SLICK -- 87 SAYS THIS IS A
LOCK FOR MITCHELL.
BUT THE JAZZ MIGHT LOSE STILL.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, YOU ARE
WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
THE NEXT UP IS SETH CURRY.
OVER 2.5 -- 3 PLAYERS.
THAT'S LESS MONEY, ERIN.
DO YOU LIKE THIS?
>> YES.
CLUB MONEY.
YOU HAVE TO TAKE THIS.
HE IS AVERAGING THIS NUMBER
RIGHT NOW OR 3 POINTERS  PER
GAME.
ADD TO THE FACT THAT -- WILL
NOT BE ON THE FLOOR.
KINDLY GIVES OTHER PLAYERS EVEN
MORE CHANCES TO SHOOT THE BALL
SO, DEFINITELY TAKE THE OVER ON
PLUS MONEY.
>> I LIKE IT.
I LIKE IT.
STEPH CURRY HAS BEEN -- LATELY.
HE HAS GOT THAT CLUTCH GAME
GOING FOR THAT PHILADELPHIA
76ers TEAM.
HE'S A LASH BROTHER.
GO GET 2.5-3. +1, GO GET IT.
LET ME HOP INTO THE COMMENTS.
I GOT ROBERT MARK SAID THAT IS
A LOCK.
THAT IS A LOCK.
STEPH CURRY, SHOUT OUT TO YOU
ROBERT MARK 2 TO 3. YOU ARE
WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
FINALLY, WE HAVE ANDRE DRUMMOND
TO GRAB OVER 13.5 REBOUNDS,
SITTING AT MINUS 102.
ERIN, DO YOU LIKE THIS ONE?
>> SO, ANDRE DRUMMOND IS
CURRENTLY AVERAGING 18 REBOUNDS
PER GAME IN THE LAST 4 GAMES
WITH -- OUT.
I LIKE THIS LINE -- RIGHT NOW
CONSIDERING THAT 13.5, I MEAN,
I FEEL LIKE YOU HAVE TO TAKE
THE OVER ON THAT.
EVEN THOUGH -- ONE OR TWO, I
GET IT MINUS MONEY BARELY.
YOU'VE GOT TO GET THE OVER ON
THAT ONE, TOO.
>> GOT TO TAKE THE OVER.
I LIKE YOU, ERIN.
I AM FOLLOWING.
I LOVE THE STUFF THAT YOU JUST
DROP, TOO.
SAYS RECORDED 18 REBOUNDS PER
GAME IN THE LAST 4 GAMES.
THIS LINE WAS SITTING AT 13.5.
JUST DO THE MATH, PEOPLE.
DO THE MATH.
ERIN IS PROVIDING THE
STATISTICS.
DO THE MAP.
I AM WRITING WITH A. I AM
WRITING WITH IT.
LET ME SEE WHAT THE PEOPLE ARE
WRITING WITH.
LET ME SEE IF THE PEOPLE IS
WRITING WITH THIS.
AIN'T AFRAID.
42 SAYS NO.
SAYS NO.
--
>> -- GOING TO BE DOWN THERE
GRABBING THEM.
>> C RONA SAYS DRUMMOND IS THE
REBOUND KING.
WITH JOELLE OUT, IT IS A LOT OF
--.
WE ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
WE LOVE YOUR VIBES.
ERIN, WE KNOW PEOPLE AT HOME.
WE KNOW THEY ALL  LOVE THE
FANDUEL -- PARLAY.
SO, WE ARE BETTING -- NOW
GIVING, BUILDING OUR OWN AND
GIVING YOU GUYS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO RIDE WITH US.
AND TONIGHT ON INSIDE THE NBA
PREGAME SHOW, CHUCK IS GOING TO
LOOK AT OUR PARLAY AND PICK HIS
FAVORITE LEG.
BEFORE I TELL YOU WHAT IT IS, I
NEED YOU TO GET IN THE COMMENTS
AND TELL ME, WHAT DO YOU THINK
OF THE PARLAY?
WHICH LEG OR LOCK AND WHICH
LEGS ARE NOT?
THIS WEEK, I AM LOOKING AT SOME
WARRIORS TAKING ON THE NET.
OF COURSE, WE ARE GOING TO
COVER THIS GAME.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
STARTING IT OFF, ERIN, YOU
MIGHT CALL IN THE  -- YOU MIGHT
CALL HIM STEPH CURRY, BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT I LIKE TO CALL HIM.
30.
30 -- GO MAKE MORE FOR 3'S.
JUST TO THAT IN -- TO MAN UP.
LET'S DO ONE.
WE TALKED ABOUT KEVIN DURANT.
I MENTIONED IT TO YOU GUYS HOW
I THINK THAT NOBODY CAN GUARD
HIM.
NOT EVEN --.
>> PROBABLY GOING TO WIN THE
DEFENSIVE PLAYER OF THE YEAR.
PROBABLY.
BUT, HE STILL CAN GUARD SLIM.
SO, KD, GO GET 30 POINTS
TONIGHT.
GO GET 30 BIG-TIME GAME AND
KATIE SHOWS UP IN THOSE BIG-
TIME GAMES.
MOVING ONTO JAMES HARDEN.
I THINK THAT IS GOING TO BE A
HEAVY DOSE OF JAMES HARDING AND
KEVIN TO RENT FOR THE NET.
SO, WITH THAT BEING SAID, JAMES
HARDING, GO GET 20 POINTS.
THAT IS ALL WE NEED.
WE ONLY 20.
MOVE, MOVING ON, ERIN.
ACTUALLY, ERIN.
I NEED A FIVE CHECK.
I NEED A VIBE CHECK.
>> YOU NEED A VIBE CHECK?
YOU KNOW CURRY COULD
POTENTIALLY GO UP.
YOU KNOW KD HAS ALREADY HAD --
OVER 30+ POINTS AND THEN WE
HAVE HARDENS 20 -- POINTS.
THAT'S WHAT IS AVERAGING RIGHT
NOW.
HE HAS SOME GATES HE HAS GONE
UP AND RECENTLY HE HAS HAD 30
POINTS AGAINST THE PELICANS
LAST FRIDAY.
AGAIN, THE PELICANS.
BUT STILL, HE IS STEPPING UP
AND SOME OF THE GAMES.
-- HITTING OVER --.
OBVIOUSLY EXPECTING A LOT OF
THE STARS TO GO OUT.
WE WILL SEE HOW THAT DYNAMIC
WORKS TONIGHT.
>> THANK YOU, ERIN FOR THE VIBE
CHECK  I FELT THE VIBES.
I FELT THOSE GOOD VIBES.
AND, WE ARE GOING TO ROUND THIS
ONE OFF WITH ANOTHER SUPERSTAR.
DREAM ON GREEN.
DREAM ON GREEN GRABBED EIGHT
REBOUNDS.
ERIN,  I'VE THE FIRST THREE
PICS.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING ABOUT THIS
LAST ONE?
>> I MEAN, DREAM ON GREEN,
REBOUNDS, THERE ALWAYS -- THE
OVERS.
A+ IS WHAT HE'S AVERAGING RIGHT
NOW -- ESPECIALLY IN A BIG-TIME
GAME.
>> CUBICLE.
WE GOT THE GOOD VIBES FOR ERIN.
LET'S PULL UP THIS TICKET SO WE
CAN SHOW THE PEOPLE AT HOME ,
YOU GUYS $400 DOWN, THAT IS
WHAT YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH.
A COOL 500.
A COOL 500 AND SOME CHANGE.
CHANGE.
I LIKE THAT, TOO.
YOU GUYS CAN GET ON FANDUEL AND
RIGHT -- BEFORE I GET INTO THE
COMMENTS.
U GRADING THE YARD BETTING
PARLAY?
>> I'M GOING TO GIVE THIS ONE
IN A MINUS.
BUT GIVEN A FULL A. BECAUSE ALL
OBVIOUSLY ALL OF THE STARS HAVE
TO -- THIS CHANCE IT HAPPENS.
I'M ALL FOR THE PARLAY, GIVING
IT AN A-. I THINK THIS IS THE
FIRST A I HAVE GIVEN OUT,
BASICALLY.
A+, A, AND A MINUS.
>> THIS IS THE FIRST A THAT
ERIN GAVE UP.
THOSE ARE REALLY GOOD
THOUGHTS.
-- AND EIGHT -- IN THE COMMENT.
GIVING OUT HOODIES JUST FOR THE
GOOD VIBES.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS.
ABOUT TO SEE IF THEY ARE
TALKING WITH OUR PARLAY.
MIKE C RITTER SAYS -- ROCKING
WITH A SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
MIKE, YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
A HOODIE.
HERE WE GO.
I GOT DG 278 SAYS 7 BOARDS FOR
GREEN TONIGHT.
THOSE ARE BAD VIBES.
BUT FORTUNATELY, WE ARE STILL
GIVING YOU A HOODIE.
I GOT ONE MORE IN MAY, ERIN.
ONE MORE IN MAY.
ACTUALLY, I AM GOING TO GIVE
AWAY A JERSEY.
I AM GOING TO GIVE AWAY A
JERSEY, ERIN.
I AM FEELING GENEROUS TO GIVE
AWAY A JERSEY AND I AM IN THE
COMMENTS.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS --.
>> I HAVE SEEN G QUINN 24.
G QUINN 24 SAYS OUR PARLAY
LOOKS LIKE EASY MONEY AND THEN
HE MENTIONED -- SHOUT OUT TO
YOU G QUINN 24.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY.
ERIN, HOP IN THERE.
WHAT IS YOUR FAVORITE COMIC?
>> P.J.
KEATS 0307.
JO, GREG AND ERIN.
-- MAYBE AVERAGES 5. KB IS
AVERAGING ONLY 30 GAME.
USUALLY SCORE OVER 30 AGAINST
HIS FORMER TEAM.
-- 20 IN THIS LEAGUE.
YOU WOULD GRAB OVER 8 REBOUNDS.
THAT WAS A LONG,.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
WE HAVE TO GIVE HIM A HOODIE.
>> YES, YES, YES.
LOVE THE VIBES.
LEVITATE.
ERIN, THE BULLS ARE LOOKING HOT
RIGHT NOW.
>> THEY ARE.
>> THE BIG THREE.
THE MARKET ROSEN, ALONZO PAUL
AND ZACH LEVINE WENT OFF LAST
NIGHT.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
HERE WE GOT ZACH LEVINE DRIVING
BASELINE.
JUMP WHEN ZACH LEVINE IS
JUMPING.
AND THEN, OH, MY GOD.
ALONZO LOOK LIKE HE IS BACK AT
UCLA.
-- FROM THE CORNER.
AND LOOK AT MY GUY.
A LOOK.
THE POETRY IN MOTION.
HE LOOKS LIKE -- I GREW UP
IDOLIZING KOBE.
THAT WAS TO MARKET ROSEN WITH A
SHOT.
I -- YOU GUYS TO GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME OF THE
BULLS CAN WIN IT ALL.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE LATEST
ODDS.
THE BULLS ARE CURRENTLY SITTING
AT.
PLUS, 39 -- TO WIN THE FINALS.
ERIN, THAT'S  A GOOD VALUE.
>> OBVIOUSLY, IT IS GOOD VALUE
CONSIDERING IT'S -- 3900 RIGHT
NOW.
IT IS A TEAM THAT PEOPLE ARE
BETTING ON LIKE THE WARRIORS
AND THE GNATS TO WIN IT ALL.
KIND OF LIKE ONE OF THOSE
LONGSHOTS PEOPLE ARE LIKING.
IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE BULLS
RIGHT NOW WITHOUT DJOKOVIC.
THEY ARE STILL STAYING AFLOAT
-- AS WE JUST SAW IN THAT CLIP.
THERE 10-4 WITH BIG WINS OVER
THE NEXT LAKERS-FLICK CLIPPERS
MATCH.
-- 5 GAMES TO THE WARRIORS.
SO, I MEAN, ABSOLUTELY
IMPRESSIVE AND I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE GOING -- ABOUT THIS
TEAM AND WHEN THEY GET IT OUT
AT 3900 RIGHT NOW, I WOULD GRAB
IT BEFORE --.
THEY KEEP WINNING.
>> YES.
ERIN IS  SAYING TAKE IT.
SHE SAYS PUT SOME MONEY ON IT.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS.
I WANT TO SEE WHAT THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT, ERIN.
I WANT TO SEE WHAT THE COMMENTS
ARE TALKING ABOUT  JT FOR MVP
SAYS NO.
HE SAYS NO.
MARCH 1 SAYS I THINK THE BULLS
NEED MORE VETERAN LEADERSHIP.
SHUT OUT?
ONE.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
D BOY 22 SAY -- A ROCKING WITH
THE BULLS.
LITTLE BLAME YOU.
DIEBEL D BOY.
THE BULLS ARE A GOOD TEAM.
THEY ARE A GOOD TEAM BUT I LIKE
THE GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS.
THINK THEY HAVE STRENGTH IN
NUMBERS.
2.0.
WE WON WAS STRENGTH IN NUMBERS
BACK IN 2015.
STRENGTH IN NUMBERS 2.0.
WE GOT THE YOUNG GUYS.
WE GOT THE VETERANS.
-- PLAY IS COMING BACK.
>> IT MIGHT GET NASTY FOR THE
REST OF THE LEAGUE, ERIN.
I THINK IT MIGHT BE TIME TO
TAKE THIS ON HOME, ERIN.
>> YEAH.
>> THANK YOU GUYS.
THANK EVERYBODY FOR TAPPING
INTO THE GROUP CHAT PRESENTED
BY FANDUEL.
REMEMBER WHAT YOU LEARN TO
TODAY.
THE WARRIORS THAT'S THREE BY
TWO WAS A LOCK.
THIS IS GOING OFF.
GET ON THE FANDUEL APP AND TELL
THE VR,  B/R BETTING GAME
PARLAY . -- INSIDE MBAS GAME
SHOW.
-- HIS FAVORITE -- PARLAY.
WE WILL BE BACK NEXT WEEK,
GIVEN OUT MORE HOODIES, MORE
JERSEYS.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY, MORE
LOCKS.
IF YOU WANT A HOODIE TODAY, WE
WILL DMU.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I AM GOING TO GIVE OUT ONE MORE
HOODIE RIGHT NOW JUST FOR THE
FUN OF IT.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS, MAN.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS.
I THINK -- THE HEAT ARE LOOKING
PRETTY GOOD THIS YEAR.
-- SAYS THE HEAT IS LOOKING
PRETTY GOOD.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, AND SHOUT OUT
--.
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
-- YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
MAKE SURE YOU GUYS -- RIDE WITH
US, FOLLOW US ON SOCIAL
ALONGSIDE ERIN DOLAN, I AM GREG
IVORY.
--.
PEACE.
>>